Hal Varian: Okay, I'm Hal Varian.
I'm the chief economist here at Google, and
it's my pleasure to introduce Yoram Bauman.
He claims to be the world's only "stand-up
economist."
And I thought, "Gee, there's a chance for
entry here.
I could maybe try this myself."
And when Ann told me to do the introduction,
I said, "Is that really fair?" because after
all, I'm a really tough act to follow. [laughter]
But despite this, you know, I said, "Okay,
I'll give it a try."
And, "What's so hard about being a stand-up
economist?
After all, you just go to Google; you type
in 'economics jokes.'" So I tried that.
And then, a few minutes later, I typed in
"funny economics jokes." [laughter]
And then, I tried "funny economics jokes I
haven't heard."
And you know, it just goes on.
I realize there was more to it than really
met the naked eye.
But I did come up with a story that I want
to use to introduce him.
I'm not sure if this specifically applies
to economists, but at least it's a nice academic
story.
It's about the full professor and the associate
professor who are holding a debate about what
fraction of sex is fun and what fraction is
work.
So the full professor says, "75 percent work.
25 percent fun."
And the associate professor says, "No. It's
50/50."
So they're arguing, they're getting citations,
they're Googling things -- and an assistant
professor comes by.
They ask his opinion.
He says, "Well, I think it's 75 fun and 25
percent work."
So they argue along for awhile.
Finally, a research assistant comes by.
They say, "What's your opinion?"
The research assistant says, "This is totally
obvious.
It's obvious. It's 100 percent fun."
He said, "How could you be so sure?"
He said, "Well, if there were any work involved,
they'd make us do it." [laughter]
So, with that, I would like to introduce -- not
the assistant professor, not the associate
professor, not the full professor -- the dean
of economic comedy -- Yoram Bauman.
>> [Applause]
Yoram Bauman: Thank you for that lovely introduction.
The setup was a bit long, but the punch line
was good.
I should -- before I forget, I should show
you my T-shirt. [laughter]
It says, "Stimulate the economy. Buy me a
drink."
I used to wear one that said, "Enjoy capitalism,"
sort of in the Coca-Cola lettering.
But, as long as unemployment is above whatever
-- 9 percent -- I think that that one's in
the closet.
I also forget to tell people, "Here's a joke
that I'm really proud of," because it's not
very often that you can make up a knock-knock
joke.
But I made up a knock-knock joke.
It's an economics knock-knock joke that's
sweeping England.
So I have to put on my terrible British accent.
Ready? Here we go.
Q [Imitating a British accent] Knock knock.
A Who's there?
Q Economist.
A Economist who?
Q Ei cah na missed the financial crisis, but
I promise I'll do better next time.
[laughter]
And the great thing about that joke is that
I'll be able to keep telling that forever,
right?
Because whatever happens in the world economy,
you can be pretty sure that, as an economist,
I'll be able to say that "Ei cah na missed
it," right?
Anyway, so it's a pleasure to be here with
all of you today.
And, in Hal's honor, I thought I would start
with a piece called, "What to Expect When
You're Expecting the Nobel Prize." [laughter]
So for any of you that are -- well, first
of all, I should say that I also teach part-time
at a high school in Seattle.
And I share this with my high school students.
And I said, "Do you guys get the joke?"
And one of them said, "Isn't there like a
baby book called 'What to Expect When You're
Expecting?'"
And I was like, "Yeah, that's very good. How
did you know that?"
And he said, "I saw it in the movie 'Knocked
Up.'" [laughter]
So that's how education happens these days,
I guess.
So this is "What to Expect When You're Expecting
the Nobel Prize."
So, first of all, you should expect an early
morning phone call from a long-dead economist.
So, when you win the Nobel Prize -- just in
case you're getting ready for that -- they
call you up at a reasonable hour Sweden time
I guess, but it's 6:00 in the morning East
Coast time -- 3:00 in the morning West Coast
time -- when they tell you that you won the
Nobel Prize.
And then, a fellow calls up from the Nobel
Prize website and does an interview with you
that they record and transcribe and then post
on their website.
So here's some snippets from the Nobel Prize
interview.
So, the first one is with Edmund Phelps in
2006.
And the interview is conducted by the editor
in chief of NobelPrize.org, whose name you'll
see in a moment.
So here's the interview, "Hello, may I speak
to Professor Phelps, please?"
And he says, "Who's calling?"
And the response is, "I'm from the Nobel Foundation,
and my name is Adam Smith."
[laughter]
And Edmund Phelps says, "Ha ha ha."
And then, Adam Smith says, "I know it could
be a hoax call with a name like that.
It's a terrible burden I carry." [laughter]
So, one of the things that you see from these
transcripts of these interviews with the Nobel
Prize winners is part of what I think US Weekly
should start running a segment called, "Nobel
Prize winners: They're just like us."
So here's more from Edmund Phelps.
The question comes in, "How are you going
to celebrate winning the Nobel Prize?" Right?
And he says, "Well, right now I'm thinking
about breakfast." [laughter]
And Adam Smith says, "Yeah, I bet it's got
to be a 2-egg day at least."
And then, Edmund Phelps starts talking about
cholesterol.
Here, Edmund's scared of cholesterol for a
long time.
But I understand the white of the egg is quite
safe.
I'll ask my wife whether perchance she has
an egg in the house.
One of the funniest exchanges in the transcripts
comes from Leonid Hurwicz, who's the oldest
person to win a Nobel Prize in any field.
So he and his wife Evelyn -- and this is their
phone call from October 2007.
So, the phone call comes in, "Good morning,
Professor Hurwicz."
And he says, "Hello?"
And the other end says -- and his wife says,
"He's hard-of-hearing." [laughter]
And the Nobel Prize dialer says, "I'm sorry,
I'll speak louder.
Can you hear me now?"
And his wife says, "Yes." [laughter]
And then, "Thank you. My name is Adam Smith."
And awghh! [Laughter]
So, these transcripts are actually quite funny.
And one of the things that they used to do
that they no longer do -- they used to ask
the Nobel Prize winner to explain in simple
layperson's terms what they won the Nobel
Prize for.
And they no longer ask them that question.
And instead what they do is, they tell them
what they won the Nobel Prize for.
And then, they say, "Is that right?" [laughter]
So then, all the Nobel Prize winner has to
do is say "yes."
And it actually is -- like, one of the challenges
there is really explaining, I think, your
research in real simple terms.
And so, I'm here promoting this book, "The
Cartoon Introduction to Economics," which
is a super fun book.
Really, it was really fun to work on the book
with Grady Klein, who's not an economist,
but he now knows a fair amount about economics
and is a terrific illustrator.
It was a neat format -- kind of "graphic nonfiction."
And one of the fun pieces that we have throughout
the book are these cartoons about "Congratulations,
You Win the Nobel Prize." So here's Jim Tobin
saying, "Don't put all your eggs in one basket."
And the king of Sweden says, "Congratulations,
you win the Nobel Prize."
And this was actually based on a true story.
And this was the impetus for this line of
jokes, because his obituary in the New York
Times told the story about how, when he went
to accept the Nobel Prize and went to give
his -- at the press conference, the reporter
said, "Well, you know, explain what you won
the Nobel Prize for."
And he did it for Portfolio Selection Theory,
which is about investment stuff.
And he said, "Well, like there's alpha and
there's beta."
And the reporters were like, "No, no, no -- that's
too hard," right?
"Make it simple."
And he said, "Well, it's kind of like 'Don't
put all your eggs in one basket.'"
And then, headlines around the world the next
day said, "Economist wins Nobel Prize for
'Don't Put All Your Eggs in One Basket." [laughter]
So this is a true story, and it was the impetus
for the other jokes that we have on this.
So here's John Nash who won for Game Theory,
who's figured out the optimal strategy for
"Rock, Paper, Scissors."
George Akerlof, who won for "Adverse Selection,"
which is related to individual health insurance
markets, saying, "Buying an individual health
insurance policy can be a real pain in the
neck."
Joseph Stiglitz "Sometimes the Invisible Hand
is Invisible Because It's Not There." [laughter]
-- which is actually a classic Joseph Stiglitz
line.
Daniel Kahneman, "Human beings are not always
rational."
And so, he's actually a psychologist who won
the Nobel Prize in economics for sort of his
pioneering work in behavioral economics and
looking at, you know, "When do people really
fulfill sort of the rational model that economists
sometimes use?"
So, those are some of the cool panels from
the cartoon book.
And then, here's one -- I think -- my prediction
is that Marty Weitzman from Harvard is going
to win one of these days for his work on environmental
economics.
And since I'm an environmental economist,
I always bet on Marty.
Harvard runs a betting pool every year for
the Nobel Prize.
So, I lost five dollars last year, because
he didn't win.
But he did kind of pioneering work on this
idea that I'll come back and chat about a
little more later on.
So, I do call myself "The World's First and
Only Stand-up Economist."
I really only have one thing going for me
and that's low expectations. [Laughter]
Actually, that's not true.
I have one other thing going for me -- I get
to make fun of macroeconomists.
You know, I'm a real economist, because I
can make fun of sub-disciplines that are totally
indistinguishable to people on the outside.
You know, like people in Washington State
-- where I live -- make fun of people in
Oregon.
People in Alabama make fun of people in Mississippi.
People in prison make fun of people in graduate
school. [laughter]
I did go through five years of graduate school.
I got my Ph.D. in economics only to decide
that I wanted to do stand-up comedy.
You can imagine how much this thrilled my
father.
He told me I'd never make it as a stand-up
economist, and I said, "Why not?"
And he said, "There's no demand." [laughter]
First joke I ever told on stage.
I said, "Don't worry about it. I'm a supply-side
economist." [laughter]
I just stand up and let the jokes trickle
down.
I believe in the Laffer Curve.
You can also tell I'm a real economist, because
I can translate plain English into incomprehensible
gibberish.
But briefly, while I was in graduate school,
I had the opposite ability -- I could translate
economic gibberish into plain English.
And that's where this next bit I want to do
for you comes from.
I think some of you may have seen this on
YouTube.
If you have, don't worry -- there's new stuff
coming -- but, this is Mankiw's Principles
of Economics.
So Greg Mankiw, a Harvard professor, chair
of the Counsel of Economic Advisors for President
Bush for a couple of years -- which, I'm guessing,
is probably not at the top of his resumé.
Also wrote the best-selling economics textbook
in the country.
It's based on these ten principles.
I know the font is small, but I generally
tell people not to bother reading these.
Just take my word that you pretty much need
a Ph.D. in economics to understand them.
Fortunately, I have one.
So, I've taken it upon myself to translate
these principles for the more fortunate.
We're going to begin by separating them into
the first seven principles, which are microeconomics,
and the last three, which are macroeconomics
-- the difference of course being that microeconomists
are wrong about specific things and macroeconomists
are wrong about things in general. [laughter]
Beginning with the macroprinciples -- eight,
nine, and ten -- these all have the exact
same translation, namely "Blah, blah, blah."
[laughter]
As proof I need only remind you that macroeconomists
have successfully predicted nine out of the
last five recessions. [laughter]
And it's further proof we can now go up one
font size.
So, let's go back to the microprinciples.
The first one -- People Face Trade-offs.
The translation here is easy, "Choices are
bad."
This is a simple syllogism -- trade-offs are
bad.
Any time you have choices, you have trade-offs,
therefore choices have to be bad.
As evidence that I'm actually driving the
research literature in economics, here's a
paper that came out in 2008 called, "Why Fewer
Options may be Better." No duh.
If you don't understand why choices are bad
though, take a look at the second principle
-- "The Cost of Something is What You Give
Up to Get It."
Translation: "Choices are Really Bad."
Now, I have a simple demonstration of this
fact.
Let's say that somebody offers you a Snickers
bar, all right -- that you value at a dollar.
All right?
Then what you are loosely going to think of
as your economic profit in this situation
is the dollar of this Snickers bar minus the
cost of what you go up to get it, which is
nothing.
Your economic profit is a dollar.
Thanks, Google. [laughter]
Now, to begin to see why choices are bad.
Imagine someone offers you a choice between
the Snickers bar that you value at a dollar,
right? -- and some M&Ms that you value at
70 cents.
Okay, now your economic profit is only 30
cents.
You begin to understand why choices are bad.
The worst possible situation, in fact, is
being offered a choice between a Snickers
bar and an identical Snickers bar. [laughter]
Now, people who are not trained in economics
might think that that's no different than
just being offered one Snickers bar, but that
kind of sloppy thinking will never get you
a tenure-track position. [laughter]
Summarizing then: Choices are bad. Choices
are really bad.
I'm not going to beat around the bush with
you people.
If you don't understand why choices are bad,
you're probably stupid. [chuckles]
Moving on. Principle Number 3 -- rational
People Think of the Margin.
Translation: People are stupid. [laughter]
It is immediately obvious to the most casual
observer with the meanest intelligence that
people do not think of the margin.
Nobody goes to the grocery store and says,
"I'm going to buy an orange.
I'm going to buy another orange. I'm going
to buy another orange."
That joke only makes sense to economists.
[laughter]
People don't think like that, all right?
But if people don't think of the margin -- and
if, as Mankiw says, "Rational people DO think
of the margin" -- we are led to a most unhappy
conclusion, "People are not rational."
People, in other words, are stupid.
But before you despair for humanity, take
a look at the next principle -- People Respond
to Incentives.
Now, the dictionary says that 'incentive'
is a noun.
That means "Something that influences to action.
Synonym: motive."
So when Mankiw says that people respond to
incentives, what he's saying is that people
are motivated by motives.
You might think this is a bit like saying
that "Tautologies are tautological," right?
I mean, people would have to be pretty stupid
to be unmotivated by motives.
But remember, Principle 3 -- [laughter] -- People
are Stupid.
Hence, the need for Principle 4 to tell us
that People Aren't That Stupid. [laughter]
Summarizing again -- we move on to every economist's
favorite topic -- free trade.
Principle 5 -- trade can make everyone better
off.
Translation: Trade can make everyone worse
You may wonder how the translation of Principle
5 is the opposite of the principle itself.
I have a simple proof of this fact that will
blow your mind.
Here we go. I want you to compare two statements.
One of them is, "Trade can make everyone better
off" and the other one is "Trade will make
everyone better off."
Now, if you had to pick one of those two statements
to put in your best-selling economics textbook,
right?
It's no contest. The second statement is clearly
better.
But Mankiw uses the first statement instead.
And if you think about "Why?" there's only
one possible explanation.
The second statement has got to be wrong.
[laughter]
In other words, trade can make some people
worse off, and from there, it's just a hop,
skip, and a jump to "Trade can make everyone
worse off." [laughter]
I figured some of you had some questions about
this, so I added a footnote with some details
-- eat your heart out. [laughter]
Now that we've cleared that up, I want you
to see the last two principles follow immediately
from Principle 5 in its translation, right?
Markets are usually a good way to organize
economic activity.
In other words, Governments are Stupid.
Governments can sometimes improve market outcomes.
Governments aren't that stupid.
Follow immediately from five in its translation,
if trade can make everyone better off, then
what the heck do we need government for? Just
let people trade, right?
But, if trade can make everyone worse off,
we better have a government around to stop
people from trading, right?
So there are the ten principles of economics
translated.
And what I want you to notice here is how
subtle economics is, all right?
Like, "People are stupid, but they're not
that stupid."
"Governments are stupid, but they're not that
stupid."
The only thing that's not subtle in economics
is that "Choices are always really, really
bad."
So, I filmed this at a science convention
and put it up on my website, standupeconomist.com
-- and also on YouTube -- a couple years
ago, not thinking very much of it.
And I'm a little embarrassed to say that it's
heading for a million hits on YouTube -- [whistling
& applause] -- which is a lot for economics
jokes, okay? [laughter]
Not a lot for videos about like, puppies,
but it's a lot for economics jokes.
And many of the hits are because the video
was posted on Greg Mankiw's blog.
It turns out that he's a fan of my parody,
or at the very least comes from the, "There's
no such thing as bad publicity" school of
thought.
And, in fact, I got to perform in his class
at Harvard.
He teaches the introductory Ec 10 class at
Harvard, and I got to perform in his class
as the last leg of my 2008 Supply-Side World
Tour -- [laughter] -- which was mostly a trip
to Israel with my father. [laughter]
But as long as I was there, I did some comedy.
And then, on my way back, I stopped at Greg's
class at Harvard.
And he told us -- he wasn't going to tell
his students that I was coming.
He just said there was a surprise guest who
was coming to class.
But then he had to tell them that I was coming,
because some students came to his office hours
and said that there was a rumor going around
campus that Ben Bernanke was coming to class.
[laughter]
I like to think that they got the better end
of the deal on that one, but. [laughter]
So, this routine is what I like to think of
as part of a renaissance in economics humor.
The idea of a renaissance -- or a resurgence
-- in economics humor may come as a surprise
to those of you who didn't know that there
was ever a first 'surgence' of economics humor.
But in fact there was.
It was in the 70s and in the early 80s and
included papers like "A Theory of Interstellar
Trade" by Paul Krugman, [laughter] which is
a fabulous paper.
And I'm thrilled to say that we're going to
be publishing it in Economic Inquiry 30 years,
or whatever, after he wrote it. So, Paul Krugman
won the Nobel Prize two years ago for his
work on Trade Theory.
And he's also a big fan of science fiction.
And this paper is about if you have interstellar
trade -- so, if you have trade between the
solar systems -- then you probably have spaceships
that are traveling close to the speed of light.
So you no longer have time simultaneity.
So, the question is, "Which clocks do you
use for calculating interest rates?" [laughter]
The clocks on the spaceships or the clocks
on the planets?
Truly an amazing, amazing hilarious fabulous
paper.
One, I think -- in my professional opinion
-- it's one of the top two funniest economics
papers of all time.
The other contestant being this one, "Life
Among the Econ" by Axel Unpronounceable.
[laughter] which is a fake anthropology paper
about the Econ tribe that lives in the bleak
north.
That also came out of Economic Inquiry.
I'm happy to say that I'm the humor editor
-- the miscellany editor -- for Economic
Inquiry.
So, if any of you have economics-related funny
papers, then send them my way.
I tend to get things from folks who have funny
economics papers, or -- more often -- people
who think that they have funny economics papers.
Tell you about some more recent developments
in the world of economics comedy.
This paper called "Japan's Phillips Curve,"
looks like Japan.
So, if you need a refresher on the Phillips
Curve, it's this idea that came out in the
50s and 60s that there's a trade-off between
inflation and unemployment.
You can have high inflation, low unemployment,
or vice versa.
But somewhere, you're always along that Phillips
Curve line, right?
And then, the 70s and 80s, we had stagflation
-- high inflation, also high unemployment.
Robert Lucas developed the Theory of Rational
Expectations.
Economists realized it was more complicated
-- everywhere, except in Japan.
So this paper was named the Funniest Economics
Paper of 2008.
There was considerable competition for that.
And it was written by a Canadian, Gregor Smith.
And one of the great things about this paper
is, it's linked from his website.
And the link on his website says that the
"title of the paper is also the abstract,
and frankly, most of the text." [laughter]
-- which is pretty much what we should be
aiming for in all academic papers, I think.
The rest of the paper is taken up by this
graph here. [laughter]
So, on the x-axis, we have the unemployment
rate in Japan between 1980 and 2005.
On the y-axis, we have the inflation rate.
For ease of viewing, the author rotates this
around the y-axis, right?
And then, there's a map of Japan. [laughter]
Extremely impressive research. [laughter]
Tell you a little bit of my own research in
economics humor.
So first of all, this paper is called "Incentive
Compatibility in the Hospital."
So this is an example of what's called a "pain
scale."
This is an actual thing that doctors and nurses
use to communicate with patients -- like,
if they don't share a common language, at
least you can point and indicate how much
pain you're in.
So, in the US, health care accounts for about
16 percent of GDP.
That hurts a whole lot. [laughter]
It's roughly like one-and-a-half to two times
more than most other rich countries pay for
health care.
And compounding the problem is that a lot
of those resources are wasted because of things
that health economists study like "adverse
selection" or "moral hazard."
Or the particular issue that I'm going to
focus on today is with patients who are malingering.
So malingering is an actual medical phenomenon.
Stereotypically, somebody who's lonely -- they'll
just go to the hospital and complain of low
back pain just so someone will pay attention
to them.
And this happens enough that medical professionals
have tests for malingering.
So there's what's called the Axial Load Test.
So if you complain of low back pain, they
might push down on your head like this and
ask you if the pain is getting worse, all
right?
If you go, "Ow, ow, ow, ow!" then they know
that you're faking it, okay?
Physiologically, it's now possible to have
enhanced low back pain as a result of that
axial load.
But my question is, why can't we just use
economic incentives instead, what economists
call "incentive compatibility"?
So my modest proposal is that, instead of
asking people this question, "How much does
the pain hurt?"
Instead, we should just ask them, "How much
would you be willing to pay to make the pain
go away?" [laughter]
And then, you just pick a bubble.
And so, macroeconomics -- I mentioned Robert
Lucas a few minutes ago.
He won the Nobel Prize for his work on Rational
Expectations.
So, I have what I modestly call "The Lucas-Bauman
Hypothesis."
Modestly, because I could have called it "The
Bauman-Lucas Hypothesis."
Let me show you what it says graphically.
If we look at the amount of knowledge that
we have about macroeconomics, that we've gained
over the last 150 years, right?
It's been a steady upward trend.
But if we look at our level of understanding
of the macroeconomy, [laughter], it's been
flat.
The Lucas-Bauman Hypothesis explains why.
The answer, of course, being that "Advances
in macroeconomics produce complexities in
the macroeconomy" -- think like credit-default
swaps -- that offset the theoretical advances.
Or in very simple layperson's terms, Macroeconomics
is Pointless.
[laughter] Finally, some more economics of
global warming.
So this is what I work on when I'm being an
academic.
So I'll tell some jokes, then I'll tell a
little bit of serious stuff.
Then, I'll go back and tell some more jokes
at the end.
So, there are a bunch of economists who work
on climate change.
I'm one of them.
And there are folks who also do like cost-benefit
analysis modeling of climate change.
The most famous model is Bill Nordhaus' model.
At Yale, it's called the "DICE" model -- the
"Dynamic Integrated Model of Climate and the
Economy."
A few years ago, he came up with a regional
version of this model.
That is, of course, called the "RICE" model.
For obvious reasons, there is no local version
of this model. [laughter]
I have my own model of climate and the economy.
It's called "The Value-laden, Assumption-laden,
Nicely Linear Approximation, Integrated model
of Climate and the Economy" or the "Vanilla
Ice" model. [laughter]
The Vanilla Ice Model has some theory; it
has some policy.
So, the theory actually goes back to this
footnote here, right?
-- about trade making everyone worse off.
And it's actually true in a very "made-up
economics model" sort of way that you can
have a situation where trade makes everyone
worse off.
And since this is related to climate change,
I'm just going to talk you through this for
a minute.
So, imagine we live in a small town, right?
Small town has just three people in it -- Orange,
Pink, and Blue.
They all live in this town.
Town has an air pollution problem, and they're
all good Americans, so they each have a garage
full of stuff that they don't use. All right?
So now, we're going to see some trades.
So first, Orange is going to sell a lawnmower
-- let's say -- to Pink. All right?
They both get a hundred dollars in value from
the trade.
Orange sells the lawnmower for a hundred dollars
that was just sitting in her garage.
Pink values the lawn mower at $200.
She only has to pay a hundred for it.
So she gets a hundred dollars in net benefits.
The problem is that, when Pink starts using
the lawn mower that was just sitting in Orange's
garage, all right? -- you get a little bit
of air pollution in the town.
And again, this is a made-up economics model,
right?
So maybe there's health impacts that we can
monetize at like $80 per person. All right?
Not just for Orange and Pink, but also for
Blue.
All right -- the negative externality in this
case.
So note that Orange and Pink are going to
continue to make the trade, because they each
get $20 in net benefits.
So, now we'll see another trade.
Pink sells something to Blue -- a snowblower.
They each get a hundred dollars in value from
the trade -- Pink from selling the snowblower
for a hundred dollars, Blue values it at 200,
she only has to pay a hundred, right?
But when Blue starts using the snowblower
that was just sitting in Pink's garage, air
pollution gets worse.
Maybe an additional $80 in health care costs
for everybody.
And now, we can just complete the circle.
Blue sells a leaf blower to Orange.
They get a hundred dollars in benefits.
Air pollution gets worse -- an additional
$80 in health care costs for everyone.
And now, if you add up any one of these columns,
you see that the sum of all three of those
trades together leaves everybody at minus
40.
So, this is the tragedy of the commons, the
prisoner's dilemma.
And the economic idea here is that each of
those people's trades are individually rational.
If you ask them if they want to take back
any of the trades that they engaged in, they'll
say "No." All right?
Because they get $20 in net benefits each
for each trade that they are engaged in.
But altogether, the trades end up hurting
everyone.
If you want to belabor the point and make
a connection to climate change, we could -- I
don't know -- like label the people or something.
[laughter]
So this is kind of the economic model -- a
very simple model -- the way that economists
think about climate change.
I'll mention a couple of things about climate
change.
So, I'm not a climate scientist, but I do
hang out with climate scientists at the University
of Washington and elsewhere.
So one thing to note is, carbon emissions
are going up.
People are very good at burning fossil fuels.
Projected at double roughly between 1990 and
2030.
And a lot of that growth is coming in the
developing world, all right?
So the red and the green here are the U.S.
and the rest of the rich world.
The purple is China and the yellow is the
rest of the developing world.
So very rapid projections for increasing CO2
emissions, especially in the developing part
of the world.
Second thing you need to know is just the
basics of the greenhouse effect.
So you probably learned this from Al Gore,
right?
But the idea is that you got energy in from
the sun and then some of that energy gets
radiated back out into space.
And greenhouse gases are this blanket of heat
trapping gases that partially reflect some
of that outgoing radiation back to the earth.
This is not controversial among scientists
anyway.
And one of the first people to work on this
was this fellow, Arrhenius, who was a chemist
in Sweden in 1896.
He did the first estimate of what would temperatures
-- by how much temperatures would go up if
we doubled CO2 in the atmosphere.
And his point estimate is still in the range
that climate scientists talk about today.
One big difference between where he was and
where we are now is that, he thought climate
change was going to be awesome, because he
lived in Sweden. [laughter] In 1896.
And we think it's a little -- probably going
to be a little less awesome these days.
And here's temperature trends.
So, you may see a lot of stuff in the media
about what's going on with temperatures.
And temperatures bounce around a lot, but
they're going up pretty much just like the
climate scientists projected -- by about .2,
.15 degrees centigrade per decade, and that's
projected to continue for the next couple
of decades.
Now, if you don't believe in climate change,
that's okay.
I'll find common ground with you anyway.
But, it's worth just keeping an eye on the
temperature projections.
One of the cool things about science is, they
make testable predictions, right?
And so, if you don't believe in climate change,
you just kind of wait five or ten years, and
then see what happens.
So, the economics of climate change -- which
I work on -- is pretty simple.
It's based -- that's the policy part of the
Vanilla Ice model -- and the policy part is
based on a simple idea, right -- which is
that, the way to get less pollution is to
make polluting expensive.
And you can do that sort of.
Economists talk about two flavors of that
-- one of them is like a carbon tax, the
other is an auction 'Cap and Trade' system.
We tend to think that they're pretty similar,
more similar than they are different.
And in both cases, the goal of those policies
is to raise the price of fossil fuels so that
you get capitalism and free market economics
and stuff working to develop alternatives
to promote conservation -- all that great
stuff that's the power of free enterprise.
And trying to get that to work for the environment.
So what I work on as a economist is, How do
we use the tools of economics to protect the
environment?
Fossil fuel prices are going to go up.
And lots of folks would like to get - they'd
like to get all that innovation and clean
energy and stuff without fossil fuel prices
going up.
And I happen to think that that's going to
be real hard.
I think you're going to need the price stable
to make that happen.
There's a little bit of good news.
And the good news is that, with either of
these systems -- with a carbon tax or with
auction Cap and Trade -- you get a pile of
money.
And you can do great stuff with that pile
of money.
You probably have your own ideas about spending
it on mass transit or clean energy research
or whatever.
What I talk to folks about is the idea of
using it to reduce or eliminate existing taxes.
So environmental tax reform -- revenue-neutral
tax shift -- or some of the names that folks
talk about. All right?
And the underlying idea here is that, for
economists, the way that you should organize
a tax system is, you should start by taxing
things that you want less of, instead of taxing
things that you want more of. All right?
So right now we tax employment, we tax savings,
we tax investment.
Those are all things that we'd like to have
more of.
So we shouldn't be discouraging them.
So we should get rid of some of those taxes,
and instead have taxes on carbon emissions
and things that we want less of.
So the underlying vision here that I go around
and talk to folks about is that we could be
replacing part of our tax code with carbon
pricing.
And there's actually a great model for this
north of where I am in Seattle in the province
of British Columbia. They did this.
There was -- the premier there, actually from
a right-of-center party, implemented a $30
per ton of CO2 carbon tax.
So that's like 30 cents a gallon of gasoline.
So that's not nothing.
And then, use the money -- a hundred percent
of the money went to rebate personal and corporate
income taxes at the provincial level in a
way that sort of offset impacts on low-income
households.
And a super great policy.
So I'm working with some folks in Washington
State to probably run a ballot measure or
something there.
I can always dream to make that happen in
Washington.
And it's something that you could do here
in California also, right?
And it would be a great thing for all sorts
of reasons. Even if you don't believe in climate
change, there are national security reasons,
right? -- for wanting to reduce the dependence
on foreign oil, the market price of oil.
And probably the best story I have about this
is -- I mentioned earlier, I teach at a high
school in Seattle.
It's a fancy private school, and they brought
George Will in -- the Washington Post columnist
-- to talk to the students.
And he doesn't even believe that climate change
is caused by human activity.
But I asked him if he would support replacing
the payroll tax with a carbon tax, and he
said, "Yes."
And he actually said that -- his words were
he would favor replacing the payroll tax with
a yogurt tax -- [laughter] -- is what he said.
But I don't care why he supports it, right?
It's just the idea that he happens to hate
the payroll tax so much that he's happy to
replace with it something that's roughly like
a consumption tax which a lot of economists
think is pretty good idea.
So there's kind of support -- at least across
the economic spectrum, if not the political
spectrum -- for this idea.
And it's one that sort of I spend -- it's
one that I'm going to spend my life talking
to people about.
So that's why I'm talking about it with you
also.
Thanks for bearing with me.
I'll tell you some jokes now. [laughter]
And then, we'll have some time for questions
about serious stuff or about comedy.
It's been an amazing year for economics comedy.
So let me just tell you the top five stories
in the last year in economics comedy.
Number 5 story. I got to be on the PBS News
Hour with Jim Lehrer.
>> Whoo!
Yoram Bauman: Yeah, thank you.
Now, I don't know how much you all know about
the world of stand-up comedy, but let me just
tell you this, people.
In the world of stand-up comedy, it does not
get any bigger -- [laughter] -- than the PBS
News Hour -- [laughter] -- with Jim Lehrer.
I have been getting phone calls nonstop on
my rotary dial telephone. [laughter]
It was actually in San Francisco.
They interviewed me at the Economics Association
meeting there, and it was pretty amazing.
They interviewed Ken Arrow, who won the Nobel
Prize.
They interviewed Joseph Stiglitz, who won
the Nobel Prize.
And they interviewed me. [laughter]
I felt like kind of a self-aware version of
Sarah Palin. [laughter]
I only tell that joke, because her book is
outselling mine.
And what did they ask me on my moment of TV
fame?
They asked me if I'd ever bombed on stage,
right?
And I had to confess to them that, in fact,
I had bombed on stage.
The worse show I ever did. All right?
Comedy is a violent business -- you either
kill or you bomb. All right?
And the worst show I ever did was in October
of 2008.
If you remember what the stock market was
doing in October of 2008?
I did a show for some bankers -- [laughter]
-- in Colorado Springs, all right?
Terrible -- did terrible.
And I actually did so poorly that I spent
a lot of time afterwards kind of soul-searching,
like trying to figure out what had gone wrong
with this audience of bankers in Colorado
Springs in October of 2008.
And I finally realized that I lost them -- like
where did I lost them?
And I realized that I lost them on my opening
line.
And my opening line was, "Hey, how's it going?"
[laughter]
Apparently, it wasn't going very well.
That was actually a really interesting time
to be doing comedy, because October of 2008
was also right before the election.
And in late October of 2008, I had the pleasure
of doing some comedy in Wichita, Kansas, which
I found out quickly was on kind of the conservative
end of the conservative wing of the conservative
spectrum.
And I found this out because I sat down for
dinner there with some folks I was doing comedy
for.
And, by way of introduction, one of the women
at my table said that she was afraid that,
if Obama was elected president -- she was
afraid that, in five years, she was going
to be wearing a burka. True story.
So, after the election, I sent her a catalog.
[laughter]
And I put a note on the catalog.
And the note said, "Look, I'm not trying to
rub it in, it's just that the economy needs
you to buy the burka now." [laughter]
Can't wait five years for you to buy the burka.
So that's Number 5 story in economics comedy.
Number 4 story -- competition from Austan
Goolsbee.
So Austan Goolsbee is one of Obama's chief
economic advisors.
As Hal mentioned -- as I said earlier -- I
like to call myself "The World's First and
Only Stand-up Economist."
So you can imagine how I reacted when somebody
sent me this from the Wall Street Journal
blog: Austan Goolsbee -- Stand-up Economist.
And it turns out he's been named like the
"funniest politico in D.C."
Here's a picture of him doing a little set
at the D.C. Improv.
Fortunately, I come from two fields -- stand-up
comedy and economics -- where we tend to think
that competition is pretty awesome. All right?
And so, what I did was, I posted a note on
my blog, inviting him to come to the American
Economics Association Humor Session and perform
there. All right?
I said that I welcome competition even from
the government. [laughter]
Especially from the government.
And I told him we even have a name for his
act, we would call it "Stand-up Economics:
The Public Option." [laughter] He didn't come.
But he did say he might come after he finishes
his work in D.C.
So that was the Number 4 story.
Number 3 story -- I was in discussions with
Fox Business Network about having a show -- a
regular show -- on the Fox Business Network.
Don't get too impressed -- the discussions
didn't go anywhere.
It turned out that they didn't need my help
in order to become a joke. [laughter]
Number 2 story is the book that I have out,
right -- The Cartoon Introduction to Economics.
I'm working on the macrobook.
And I'm happy to say, lots of economists have
said nice things about the book.
In particular, Greg Mankiw called it, "A Painless
Way to Learn Economics," which I thought was
especially generous of Greg, given what I
said about his book, right?
In my parody.
I mean, I think that -- really, the only thing
that I could have done that would have been
meaner to Greg Mankiw would have been to post
something on my blog calling his book, "A
Painful Way to Learn Economics." [Laughter]
which I didn't do.
But still, it was very nice of him to call
my book "A Painless Way to Learn Economics."
And you can draw all sorts of conclusions
from this -- that he's a nice guy, that he's
forgiving.
The conclusion that I draw is that Greg Mankiw
is not a game theorist.
And I know this, because we sent the book
out.
So we sent the book out for blurbs to a bunch
of folks to try to get -- you know, blurbs
for the back of the book.
And one of them was a famous game theorist
-- whose name shall not be mentioned here.
But here's the e-mail that came back from
famous game theorist about the blurb.
It says, "You're wrong; the book is great."
Say, "How about this blurb -- 'This book is
not funny at all.'" [Laughter]
You can really see how game theorists think,
right? [laughter]
Because in his mind, this is an awesome blurb
for the back of the book.
He goes on to say, "Readers are likely to
understand basic economic ideas much better
than they would from books full of equations
and real life examples." [laughter]
To this day, I still have no idea whether
or not famous game theorist actually liked
the book.
I should say, at this point, we also sent
a galley of the book to Hal Varian, trying
to get a quote from him for the back of the
book.
My apologies to Hal -- the quote did not make
the back of the book.
You can judge for yourselves whether that
was appropriate or not.
But Hal Varian's quote for the back of the
book was that it was -- he said nice things
about the book, and said that the book "Put
the cartoon before the course." [laughter]
Stand up and take a bow, Hal -- excellent!
[laughter]
So that's the Number 2 story in economics
comedy.
And the Number 1 story in economics comedy
-- I run a humor session every year at the
American Economic Association Meeting, and
the next one is going to be in Denver.
It's going to be 8 p.m. January 8, 2011.
It's the only session at the American Economic
Association Meeting that is free and open
to the public.
And so, you're all invited.
The session that we did this last year in
Atlanta was super fun. I was there.
A woman who's a grad student at Harvard, named
Jodi Beggs, was there.
She runs a website called economistsdoitwithmodels.com.
[laughter]
A fellow named Hugo Mialon, who's up for tenure
next month at Emory, presented a paper on
"The Economics of Faking Orgasms."
And a fellow who's a financial analyst by
day and by night, he sings country music songs
about economics under the stage name of Merle
Hazard.
So, he performed, and we had a super fun time.
So I invite you all to come out to Denver
in January of 2011.
Thank you for bringing me here for the day.
This has been fabulous.
And I have time to take questions if there
are some questions.
And if you have to go work or stuff, then
you can do that too.
Can you use...? Yeah, sure.
You can use this mic for questions, and I
will go to the podium.
>> Thanks.
>> [Applause]
>> Any questions?
Yoram Bauman: I suppose I should plug my website
too.
So, standupeconomist.com is my website.
There's my e-mail. You can get on my mailing
list and stuff like that.
>> [indistinct voices]
Q So, I'll break the ice.
What's the funniest thing you found on Google?
Yoram Bauman: What's the funniest thing that
I've found on Google. [pause]
I don't know. I think probably the funniest
thing that comes to mind right now is, apparently
-- I'm sure you all know about this -- but
there's something called "Let me Google that
for you" -- which one of my TAs told me about,
because they get e-mails from students that
are like, "How do I find out the population
of Japan?"
And so, I guess there's this website out there
that's called, "Let me Google that for you."
Where it's -- you know -- whatever code it
is, where you can send them an e-mail or a
website address and that the website that
actually types in for them.
You know, like when you go to the website,
it types in "Google.com" and then it types
in the question, like "What's the population
of Japan?"
And then, it kicks up the answer for them,
so.
Q Anybody else?
Yoram Bauman: I can just tell more jokes for
15 minutes.
Oh, you got to take the mic.
Q On your mailing list, do you have a separate
mailing list for your research as opposed
to your stand-up comedy?
Yoram Bauman: I don't have a mailing list
for my research.
I just -- I'm kind of -- I'm a pretty bad
economist, and I'm a pretty bad comedian,
but I'm a pretty good economics comedian.
So, I have a little bit of time for research.
If you're really interested, like I'm one
of the world experts on the impacts of climate
change on dairy production in the Pacific
Northwest.
So if that happens to be something that you're
super passionate about, then drop me a line.
I do a little bit of research, mostly coauthored
with folks who are smarter than I am.
We did a paper on whether -- one of my colleagues
at University of Washington, Elaina Rose,
and I just came out with a working paper on
whether taking economics classes makes people
selfish. [laughter]
So it's definitely true, yeah.
Q Anybody else?
Yoram Bauman: I could do ten more minutes
of comedy unless you have questions.
Oh, okay -- more questions.
Q Question relating to that -- could you tell
us like a few more jokes for the next 10,
15 minutes? [laughter]
Yoram Bauman: Do you want to hear more jokes?
>> Yeah, [clapping]
Yoram Bauman: All right. [pause]
Can I do magic tricks? I don't do magic tricks.
All right.
So I'll tell you that -- so when I started
doing comedy, I started doing a little bit
of economics jokes.
And then, I started going to open mic nights
at the Comedy Underground in Seattle.
One of the great things about comedy is that
there's no barriers to entry.
Like, anybody just shows up on Sunday night
and puts your name on a list and you get two
minutes at open mic night -- which is also
why most people don't make any money from
doing stand-up comedy.
So, I quickly realized that I had to start
doing some routines that weren't just about
economics.
I needed something easier to do jokes about.
This was in 2004.
So I started doing some jokes about the war
in Iraq that I thought would appeal to people
across the political spectrum.
So I'll do those for you now, and we'll see
whether you still like them.
The challenge with those jokes is that it's
really hard to find a political spectrum in
America.
Like, everywhere you go is either far left
or far right or whatever.
So, with your permission -- and this is the
audience participation part of the afternoon
-- I'm going to divide you up across the
political spectrum.
So you folks over here on my left -- just
for the next couple of minutes -- I need you
guys to participate.
You guys are going to be my left wing. [laughter]
That was actually an appropriate amount of
enthusiasm for the left wing. [laughter]
Watch this -- you folks over here to my right
-- all you folks over here, I need you to
participate.
You guys get to be my right wing.
>> [half-hearted cheering]
Yoram Bauman: That was good, but I need you
guys to dig down and find your inner red meat
okay? [laughter]
Put yourselves in the mind frame of people
who believe in social Darwinism.
[laughter and clapping]
Put yourselves in the mind frame of people
who believe in social Darwinism, but don't
believe in Darwin's theory of evolution. [laughter]
You guys over here. You guys are my right
wing.
>> [sparse cheering]
Yoram Bauman: That was a little better, but
when I did this in Texas last month, they
started chanting "USA." [laughter]
I want you to do that for me. You guys are
my right wing!
>> [chanting] USA! USA!
Yoram Bauman: That was okay.
You guys on the left wing, though -- you guys
are perfect. [laughter]
Because while the right wing was chanting
"USA," you were just sitting there looking
befuddled and vaguely unpatriotic. [laughter]
Don't know how it happens to the left wing;
it always does.
I haven't forgotten about you people.
You all are the most important part of the
political spectrum.
You're the swing voters. Your job is to be
clueless and apathetic.
And then, every four years, you determine
the fate of the free world. [laughter]
I know it sounds like a big responsibility,
but don't give it a second thought. [laughter]
You guys are like the idiot savants of democracy.
Of course, the most amusing parts of the political
spectrum are the far extremes.
So the far right of the political spectrum
-- you folks over there by the cafe and stuff
-- you guys get to be my libertarians.
That's cool. You can do what you want. [laughter]
Far left of the political spectrum, on this
wall over here -- far left -- you guys get
to be my libertarians. [laughter]
Did you swing voters get that joke?
Libertarians. They're not the people that
check books out for you. [laughter]
Libertarians are freedom lovers. All right?
They come in two flavors, right?
There are right wing libertarians -- they
want everyone to be free to have guns.
Left wing libertarians -- they want everyone
to be free to have drugs. [laughter]
Both wings of the libertarian party want to
abolish Social Security.
Right -- which makes total sense, because
who's going to make it to 65? [laughter]
>> [Applause]
Yoram Bauman: -- when the world is full of
pistol-packing pot heads.
All right.
I promised you some jokes about the war that'll
appeal to people across the political spectrum.
So let me start with this.
I'm going to do these jokes at West Point
next week.
So I'm going to try them out on you.
I don't care how you feel about the war.
I don't care how you feel about President
Bush or President Obama.
I think the individual troops over there deserve
our support.
So I hope you join me in a round of applause.
>> [Applause]
Yoram Bauman: Nice work, left wing.
I can't believe I have to give a disclaimer
before asking for a round of applause for
the troops, but the political situation in
this country, ladies and gentlemen, has become
so divisive.
I experienced that divisiveness firsthand
a few years ago when I moved from liberal
Seattle to conservative eastern Washington
with a bumper sticker on my car.
I brought a copy to show you here.
The bumper sticker said, "Bring the Troops
Home."
Not a big deal in Seattle, right?
But after getting my butt kicked multiple
times outside of Barnaby's pub in Walla Walla,
I decided I needed to do something different
to fit in, right?
So I traded in that bumper sticker.
I got a new bumper sticker that said, "Leave
the Troops There." [laughter]
That one didn't work either.
So then I went for something neutral, right?
I got a bumper sticker that said, "I don't
know about the troops." [laughter]
Yes, I am selling these bumper stickers.
And can I just say, this is going much better
than when I did this routine in Texas last
month?
Because when I did this routine in Texas,
this great big dude jumped up in the back.
And he was like, "That is the most offensive
bumper sticker I've ever seen!" [laughter]
Well, maybe I've been hanging out with economists
too long or something, but I took that as
a challenge.
I looked at him, and I said, "You think that's
the most offensive bumper sticker you've ever
seen?"
And I reached into my bag, and I said, "Apparently,
you haven't seen this one."
It says, "If the troops weren't all in Iraq,
I'd shoot one myself." [laughter]
Now, "This!" I said, "This is an offensive
bumper sticker."
This guy in Texas, ladies and gentlemen -- you
should have seen the look on his face.
I mean, I knew that I had won the argument
about which was the more offensive bumper
sticker.
What I didn't know was that he was going to
be an incredibly sore loser. [laughter]
Apparently what I thought of as my rights
under the First Amendment were in conflict
with what he thought of as his rights under
the Second Amendment. [laughter]
But I don't back down, people.
So when this guy asked me if I was selling
this bumper sticker too, I said "Heck, yes.
How many would you like to buy?"
He flipped out. He jumped up on the stage.
He ripped the bumper sticker out of my hand.
He got right up in my face.
He said, "I would never buy that bumper sticker
and put it on my car."
And I said, "You dummy, you're not supposed
to put it on your own car." [laughter]
>> [Applause]
Yoram Bauman: It's got instructions right
on the back.
Step 1 -- Locate Hummer.
Step 2 -- Place over gas tank.
Step 3 -- Run.
Sometimes people doubt my patriotism when
I do that routine.
So let me be clear about my point, right?
If you're driving a Humvee around Baghdad,
I want to thank you for the sacrifices that
you're making for our country.
If you're driving a Humvee around the Bay
Area, I want to put my foot up your ass.
I mean, I totally support the troops.
I have extra respect for the troops, because
I'd be such a terrible fit for the military.
No -- I mean, look at my arms. [laughter]
I'm like human veal.
If I went to boot camp, I'd be afraid the
drill sergeant would tell me to drop and give
him five push-ups.
And, as far as the military is concerned,
I only have one thing going for me.
I'm not openly homosexual.
But if they reinstate the draft, ladies and
gentlemen, that is going to change.
It is going to change in a snap. [laughter]
It's not just me, though, because that's the
military's policy, right?
If you're "out," you can't get "in."
You can't even get by if you're "bi."
So if they reinstate the draft, gay is going
to be the new Canada. [laughter]
Thanks a lot, everybody.
Have a good rest of the day.
>> [Applause]